There've been a lot of celebrity endorse products over the years.
Some have been ridiculous. Some of them cringy, Hey guys, I'm whole Cogan,
but very few of them have actually been good.
And among this pile of failing a Lister, American celeb one,
man stands above.
Aviation, American gin. If you're drinking anything else, you're drinking.
Welcome to a daily YouTube channel guys. As we know, pure quality here,
today's the first installment of marketing Mondays,
where we demystified the success, the disasters of the marketing world.
I'm going to be answering the age old question today in episode one,
how do you make people watch an edge? Traditionally, the answer has been forced,
forced down their throats with a commercial,
but it's 2021 guys that feels a little aggressive in a time where kids know
consent is cool.
So the real question is how do you make people want to watch an ad to consent to
it? The answer normally has been to use celebrities,
but the problem is it doesn't normally work out as bland,
but popular people in sterilized, scripted environments.
Something still feels off even in multimillion dollar photo shoots with the best
copy editors in the world.
You know that Chris rock really doesn't care about the 5g network of Verizon
wireless.
This is a game changer, five G five G five G five G.
Well,
not only that you could replace Chris rock with literally any celebrity and the
result would be the exact same, not exactly inspiring. So you tune out the ad,
but you know whose YouTube channel hasn't been tuned out. Ryan freakin Reynolds,
this man has accumulated almost half a billion views, just organic traffic,
no PPC required. And the content all adds for like random stuff.
You wouldn't think are viral successes, Jen. Okay.
Maybe objectively the worst alcoholic beverage. Sorry guys.
You've got budget mobile wireless and you've got dating websites. Okay.
Not exactly a recipe, a trifecta for virality,
but if you're like me and you thought that you're an idiot because millions of
people tune into this kind of content with the most popular comment,
being that this is the most popular type of ad that people would will willingly
watch.
And to the marketing skeptics like me who know that views don't equal purchases.
You should note that these ad campaigns have been enormously successful for the
companies that he's partnered with. Mint.
Mobile had a huge surge in popularity and aviation gin just sold for
$600 million. That's right. Million. Now of course,
success is never just one thing. But viral marketing always helps.
So what is he doing? Right? It's three things. It's funny.
It's self-aware and the brand always looks good. Now,
most celebrity endorsements I've realized after watching a bunch of them way too
many nail number three, the brand looks good. Let's look at that.
Chris rock commercial, right? The iPhone looks beautiful.
The whole ad actually is just this beautiful thing, but it's not funny.
It's not self-aware. And in fact, it's just all staged and boring.
Now a rare exception to this is the celebrity endorsement that hit one and two.
It's funny it's self-aware but these often come at the,
of the brand take for example, bill Burr. He's a hilarious example of this.
He always insults his sponsors as he reads them.
Right, right out of the bat. This sounds creepy to me, video doorbell,
a will insert dinging sound. What does that mean?
I was supposed to insert ding dunks. All right. Let's do that again.
Or built-in rechargeable battery.
Put your mind at ease and protect your home and your parakeet
with the video doorbell,
time magazine named one of the top 10 gadgets of 2014
Sheridan Kilmore porpoises.
Cause eventually you have to throw out the wires and they will end up in the
ocean.
But right now my listeners get the ring video doorbell for
only $174. That's $25 off the normal price.
Still kind of expensive though. You know,
it comes with a doorbell already attached. He's still making payments anyways.
Okay. You're coming out of that. It's funny.
It's self-aware but you're not going to buy a ring doorbell. If anything,
you're not going to buy it anymore.
But sitting somewhere right in the sweet spot is an ad that manages to be funny
self-aware and makes the brand look good all at once. Take for instance,
this ad within an ad,
within an ad where Ryan Reynolds buys mid-roll ad placement for his gin company.
My new movie.
Underground is so huge. You're going to want to watch it on a bigger,
better Samsung Q led TV. Oh.
Aviation gin. How'd that get there now. That's good advertising.
And if you're thinking that the only reason this ad works is because gin is fun.
Let's talk about 5g with a mobile carrier network. Okay.
It's about as exciting as dental work, but watch this.
To believe that 5g is as amazing as everyone is saying.
So we've brought in min mobile head of technology.
Rizwan Kaseem to explain it to us Riz. Well,
5g is substantially more spectrally efficient with lower latency.
So it's an order of magnitude improvement over 4g.
It seems we may never know what 5g is.
So we're just going to give it away for free with every plan until we can figure
that out.
You just got about to the master well-played Ryan Reynolds,
you managed to make 3 million people voluntarily sit through an ad.
Well-played indeed. All right. That's basically it.
I hope you enjoyed this episode of marketing Mondays.
If you did leave a comment below letting me know who you'd like to see next
featured next on marketing Mondays, it can be great advertising.
It can be terrible advertising,
but I thought we'd take a little diversion from the usual scams that we talk
about and talk about real advertising that either succeeds works really well,
crushes it or completely bombed. And we'll analyze it on this channel.
Let me know if you enjoy it, seeing the next one.